here's what would happen if you were  swallowed by a crocodile  crocodiles can be incredibly aggressive  and are responsible for more than 300  attacks on people every year  if you tried to run it might not be so  easy to escape as some crocs can run up  to 18 kilometers an hour on land  if it caught up to you the crocodile  would bite and break your leg preventing  you from getting away it would then  begin to roll you around in the water  attempting to disorient and drown you  the croc would then swallow your body  whole and you'd pass through the beast's  esophagus into its stomach  there you'd be met with rocks and help  break up the crocodile's food  over the course of a week your body  would get crushed up by the rocks and  you'd quickly be dissolved by stomach  acid  finally the crocodile would then poop  out your remains so the next time you're  near a swampy river watch out for these  things because